she hasn't had like the first boyfriend
yet well that may have changed because
Cindy Crawford's daughter is rocking a
pea necklace and everyone thinks it
stands for Pete Davidson it's the most
exciting and there's a lot of buzz
around it
Kyah Gerber attended the Women's Guild
cedars-sinai annual luncheon in Los
Angeles on Wednesday alongside her mom
Cindy and grandmother
Jennifer Hsu looking sophisticated and
chic in a button-down cream dress
pairing the look with a delicate gold
chain necklace with a sparkling pea
charm its kaya confirming her
relationship with Pete which I feel like
before it wasn't like that now it's
still not officially clear whether these
two are a thing or just friends but they
have been spotted together quite a lot
lately the 18 year old model and the
Saturday Night Live star were spotted
together in late October after a fan
snapped them spending time together at
acid Elle's in New York City and just a
few days later they were both seen
courtside at the New York Knicks game at
Madison Square Gardens
although kaya attended the game with her
dad Randy it took me a while for it to
hit like it really I was like this is
insane but I know I'm like not gonna
jinx it or anything kaya and Pete's
budding romance comes not long after the
25 year old comedians short-lived
romance with actress Margaret quale Pete
has been linked to several famous women
in recent years in 2018 he was engaged
to Ariana Grande and at the time the
pair got several tattoos commemorating
their love thanks for existing
he then dated Kate Beckinsale who is
more than 20 years his senior apparently
apparently people have a crazy
fascination with our age difference we
may stand this Kaia Pete relationship
but does he pass the test when it comes
to her famous family so dad's the tough
one what a guy I mean my brother is
really the toughest really cuz he's
close to my age so he knows everything
when et spoke with Kaia and her mom in
2017 they opened up about what her first
boyfriend would have to go through to
date her if Randi and pressed they had I
think the last one that would have an
issue with it like they'd first have to
get through my brother Baghdad so she
wouldn't yeah if they got through them
she'd be ecstatic be easy he would like
to approve anyway yes
[Music]